hello what welcome to this and the video
playing Grand Master sauerkraut is love
Gucci Chuck let's see what we get yeah
that early Bishop d7 that's interesting
let's see do we get this d5 line with 95
no we don't is playing and some kind of
Hedgehog set up after sorry in which
white quite often gets interesting play
with f4 so let's see how to do this
night h forms probably and too much i'm
trying something else and preparing it
like that and okay let's square form
okay so Queen to d2 on I can also go to
see two that's a temple so maybe to take
the temple on age seven that looks like
a nice position for white doesn't it
isn't that her isn't it it's right okay
and so what to do now okay so let's
trade that trade that good night he
cannot go i have six i believe i will
take only five and take on g6 that looks
very dangerous check okay he wants to go
97 I this is clear okay nighty for will
definitely trade this night
you
k 97-94 that looks wow that dangerous
for black g6 is hanging here hmm yeah
but why is that possible 96 95 97 now
that's not that's not playable I don't
see how that is playable i have c 5 at
the end 95-97 803 check group with reach
and quincy 7 it's not working you cannot
do that I don't think so
nadia three rook f3 queen is seven or
something c5 Queen takes c6 that since
not not going to work mr. sauerkraut
maybe a sub green one I don't know I
don't don't really believe it but came
so how to do this he's got one check
here I want to prevent the checks down
we should see for us also of course good
need to somehow make sure that the queen
is not blocking everything here and
would be really cool if I could manage
that I don't see how down
hmm covering with this let's do this I'm
I'm taking too long him while trying to
find a direct wind which is probably
wrong
and just playing the position is
probably right and see what happens
cookie 3s idea getting to the e-file
hmm mad I cannot go maybe you look F to
fergie two but could help we actually
wants to trade Queens hmm I'm not sure
about that fight if this is in my my
favor or not hard to tell ieva come come
there i don't i don't see how I'm
preventing this then I came in keeping
Queen's Own unsure about this time
morning if he trades is this now this is
a different story because he cannot
trade rooks at the end check
rookie one rookie to should be good yeah
okay I'm I think I'm okay with this now
difficult for him to play I don't see
how is not trading looks he actually
moving moving the rockaway cannot work
oh he really tries to do that so I can
taking and here Drina form can check
also first just do this first maybe a
five is a good move a five if it takes
with the Queen I have Queenie five that
wins let's do that it looks interesting
pawn takes Queen 87 also wins I didn't
see that one ok I've I taking it's got
Queenie five I shoot ok Jack it's got 25
now check check check Shh I screwed that
up check check it's what about the time
now check check check black forfeits on
time yeah boson 0 oh my god Gallo is
just a gamble at the end but of course I
had a completely winning position so
it's not completely undeserved and got
pretty much it was pretty much busted
here I couldn't really figure it out or
these six wins oh wow of course Wow now
this is amazing the engine says I'm just
slightly better here and that it can I
cannot believe it if this position is
not clearly better for white something
is wrong there was just I have two
connected pawns here why is why isn't
why just just winning him or much better
I cannot believe it we black has a
crappy sorry grab the King position
Bishop e6 well okay well compute as a is
of course perfectly defending always but
still okay so this this the engine says
is equal but now I could Queen d6 now is
equal supposedly and here I can win with
d 6 or I'm really technically not sharp
here at the moment I mean these six is
very simple for Bishop c4 I can just
just over oops sorry this is just the
end of the game check check and that's
it threatening this yeah also oh my god
what am I doing here check this is
pretty neat SOT 6 was winning and t6
again is winning and I'd simply don't
manage to put it away check EDM also
winning of course but how could I do it
so as his 70 Cal has his 7sp obvious
actually c7 King takes Queen e7 r up to
76 and wins I thought that this is
looking good but this again I can go see
7 yeah I kind of lost my nerve there a
little bit Jack Queen e7 is also winning
winning the Rookie check check I know I
have chased him out yeah check it was
panic panic time jack I had so many
Winston check check that was about the
only only continuation that did not win
on the board when we were just yeah
dashing out looks okay thanks for
watching